the 2020 NFL Draft is in the books and
we're gonna take a look at the top five
classes from this year's draft Matt
Miller and Connor Rogers Connor I have
to start with the Baltimore Ravens it
seems like they do this every year they
make history drafting the first ever
player from LSU and Patrick queen for
the Baltimore Ravens frenchers had never
done that before but also they get Jake
a table and some bleak Harrison both
from Ohio State
Justin Manabu Kade the interior pass
rusher from Texas A&M Devin Duvernay a
speedy receiver out of Texas the Ravens
were the best team in the AFC last year
until late in the playoffs the players
they added I truly believe they're
looking at the Kansas City Chiefs and
saying try to run on us now oh and we
have our own speed receiver that can
score some points yeah I absolutely love
what they did Matt I'm gonna go with the
team that who knows they could even run
into in the Superbowl that's how good
they look on paper right now that's the
Minnesota Vikings and when they came out
of round one with Justin Jefferson who
had no business falling to them I was
really excited then they got Jeff
Gladney after trading for more assets so
I think when you look at what the
Vikings did they were able to replace
the Fonz IG's
they were able to find a starting corner
for life after Xavier Rhodes I think
Rick Spielman is a guy that knows how to
play value in the draft and he knocked
it out of the park his last three days
absolutely did it Rick Spillman again
one of the best drafters in the NFL that
turned that roster over consistently
love the speed that they've added to
this roster no team to add a lot of
speed oh my goodness
buckle up Las Vegas because it's about
to get fast Henry rugs the fastest
player in the draft you came in round
one
Damon Arnett toughest nails inside
corner for Ohio State but then Lynn
Bowden Brian Edwards Tanner Muse you get
an interior offensive lineman and John
Simpson a lot of Clemson players in
there Connor but a lot of power and a
lot of speed I think the Raiders also
surveyed the AFC West and said we better
be able to score better be able to make
some explosive plays and they get some
guys who are defensive chess pieces in
our net and Muse but you can move all
over in that secondary yeah it was super
impressive I mean they also got a
starting slot cornerback in a meek
Robertson in the fourth round towards
the end of the
round so the Raiders really attacked
valium needs and they weren't afraid to
double dip at positions either to get
more points on the board now I'm gonna
go with another AFC team here and this
might be the obvious cuz they got the
first pick out of anyone that's the
Cincinnati Bengals but what they did
after taking jobber Oh Matt I'm pretty
excited I think t Higgins is another
really good above the rim target for Joe
Pearl we don't know how much longer AJ
Green is gonna be there t Higginson Joe
burrow coming in together building that
connection I think it'll be fun for
those guys to play together and then you
look at the two linebackers they were
able to take later on and Logan Wilson
the productive starter and three-year
captain from Wyoming and a keen Davis
davier from appstate when you look at
his ability and coverage outside
linebacker he can blitz
those guys are productive players that
defense quietly needed a lot of help in
the middle of everything and they were
able to grab two starting linebackers
later on all right one more team we got
to give Jerry Jones credit for the draft
that his Dallas Cowboys had they
surprised us all by taking CD lamb in
the first round but you have to applaud
the bravado go get another receiver with
Amari Cooper Michael Gallup already
there within a round two they checked
off arguably their biggest need with
Trayvon Diggs corner out of Alabama they
get Neville Gallimore to play that three
technique position on the interior out
of Oklahoma and then in day three they
just kept hitting hits reggie robinson
corner out of Tulsa Tyler Beede --is-- a
center from Wisconsin Travis Frederick
just retired you might be relying on
this guy and maybe my favorite pick the
entire draft of the Cowboys the last
pick of round five Bradley and I a
powerful pass rusher from the Utah use